get the afternoon sessions our first
speaker is there steph nvidia so we
talked about alright so first of all I'd
like to thank the organizers for
inviting me and giving me a chance to
give this talk here and this is joint
work with several people namely usually
adamek yanking chin and ending robots
and now with such a title one is of
course asking for trouble so perhaps we
should have replaced all by many of them
or we should put it should have put it
towards in front but where would be the
fun in that I shall manage to put a
question mark here as opposed to the
program yes and this is what the talk is
about and it's a it's in category theory
and I think it's one of the examples
where category theory can unify things
that are in the literature and that look
the same but you can formally say why
they are the same and this might save
work and travel for for many people okay
so what this is about is some algebraic
language theory so that is the study of
the behavior of finite machines for
example deterministic automata with
algebraic structures so in the classical
case one looks at mono it's now coming
from a category theoretic background we
saw all these different kinds of
algebraic structures with which you
study different kinds of behaviors or
sometimes same behavior we were asking
ourselves ok sister a unifying view for
this and actually building blocks from
to study these things are there in
category theory so if we want to
approach automata like this little guy
here from categorical perspective
there's a lot to build and on so for
example automatons can be captured by a
algebras & Co algebra so algebras this
goes way back to the 70s to work by Joe
goguen or
our bourbon menace quality brass is a
bit more recent let's say the last 15 to
20 years and their languages essentially
appear via initial algebra and final
call algebra so being characterized by
universal property algebra of course is
for category theory is the classical
subject going back to LA via theories
and the study of Mon arts so this is
some what we're going to look at so our
goal is a kind of a categorical
algebraic language theory using Mon arts
and in this talk I'm gonna focus on one
serum from algebraic language theory and
that's allenburg variety theorem which
states that something called varieties
of languages are in one-to-one
correspondence with Sudha varieties of
models actually that's a isomorphism of
lettuces so what are these things so to
the varieties of mana weeds are almost
like birkoff varieties or mono it's
except that you put the word finite in
two places so first of all you consider
finite mono eats and the pseudo variety
is a class of finite ma notes that's
closed under quotient sat-mon weeds and
finite products so the two occurrences
of finite is difference to book of
varieties varieties of languages on the
other hand are classes of regular
languages here that's stratified by
fixing alphabet but is raging overall
alphabets and these classes are supposed
to be closed under the boolean
operations under language derivatives
and under pre images of Molag morphisms
between free more apps so if you've got
mono eat morphism from delta star to
sigma star and the language L in V Sigma
here then it's pre images in the Delta
ok so that's Alex classical variety
theorem and now 40 years later if you
look through the literature you find
more than a dozen theorems that look
similar so there are other allenburg
type theorems on the one hand once that
consider weaker closure properties but
still talk about regular languages
so for example the ordered one by genre
Victor 14 yeah basically based on joints
immediate assist by potluck Reuter nawaz
theorem which is actually more general
in some sense also because it's not just
about regular languages is about
weighted languages one could consider
fewer moderate morphisms than all
between fremont weights or more recently
one could consider what's called local
islander type correspondences where you
fix one alphabet and then you don't
consider the preimage property so this
is from work by Myakka search click oil
and garlic down and on the other hand
there are Island back type
correspondence is probably more than the
ones that are listed here for other
finite machine behaviors so I mentioned
weighted languages already one could
look at infinite words and there's also
an older version for this one good look
at all out words rank trees binary trees
and very recently people have looked at
cost functions and we are particularly
happy that in the end we're going to
include this as an application because
in their paper they actually are so
there are these general methods and it
would be nice if this could be covered
and the answer is yes we can do this so
this talk is going to be about a general
variety theorem that covers all these as
as instances right so and what's the big
picture so what are the two main
ingredients is that you need for such a
general variety theorem well it's
monarchs and dualities it's of course a
bit over simplifying but it's a catchy
equation here so why monarchs now on the
one hand you want to generalize from
from one weeds to other algebraic
structures recognizing machine behaviors
and other algebraic structures
categorically you can capture by menards
and so they are used to model the type
of languages and the algebra is
recognizing them and that's not actually
our idea this is an idea
foo Yong shik published last year and
there's also a longer technical report
on Ike life on this so that's one side
using Mona's the other is duality kind
of place in the background if you want
to relate varieties of languages and
super varieties of mono ease and this is
I think very clear for the first time in
gaku drugoi from past paper from I cup
2008 and we've been inspired by that and
have worked on General Allen book
theorems and writer man theorems since
then and so this occurs also an hour but
duality in language theory goes back
further at least two pipe in jerz paper
in 97 one other thing I should say here
is if you compare boo Yong Chi quirks
and in ours it generalizes allenburg
type correspondences in kind two of two
orthogonal directions so whereas amico
lies work one has mon arts they're all
on sets or sorted sets while our work we
have a general iron berg theorem
previously that works on more general
categories but it always considers mono
eads so then of course if you look at
this you ask yourself ok what's the
common roof one arts one sets wanna eat
sand and arbitrary categories the common
room should be mon arts on an arbitrary
category so that's what we going to look
at so how do mon arts model the type of
languages in algebra so we want to start
with a monarch on a locally finite
variety so it's a kind of an algebraic
theory on an algebraic theory but don't
worry in most instances this d here is
going to be just sets opposites and for
some applications when each sorted sets
or vector spaces i'm also suppressing
the sorted setting here and also the
ordered it could be an ordered variety
so that's in the paper in the talk i'm
just gonna
I invited variety there's going to be a
two sorted example all right so that's
what's fixed and then one can give in
this setting a very general definition
of what the languages name is just a
morphism from the free algebra on some
object of tea which we think of as an
alphabet to some object / of outputs so
so there is a category several times
when you say locally find variety aha so
that means it's a finite element free
algebra some finite sets are finite so
it's a variety with this property
based on the Sun based on set or or post
it if it's an order so those are the two
cases we consider so and what is with
the general definition of language you
of course can capture ordinary languages
by just taking the fremont wait ma not
on sets so T Sigma Sigma star and oh to
be the two elements set so then that's
just a predicate on Sigma star which is
a language if you want to do something
more fancy like languages of finite and
infinite works you immediately need to
sort it setting and so they're your ma
not what it does well he has just said
what it does if you take the two sorted
set with Sigma and empty set in the
second sort it's doing this so that's
the monitor of free Omega semigroups and
as the output object here you take two
elements in both source and it turns out
that the languages are just the
languages of finite and infinite words
and then for other examples you have to
instantiate data differently so for
example for weighted languages you take
vector spaces for three languages you
need three sorted sets of course
functions you need post-its and so on
and so forth I can't really show you all
the more than 12 examples in detail here
and also language recognition is kind of
straightforward because you say a
language like this morphism from t sigma
20 is recognizable by algebra if it
factors through some finite quotient
algebra so here this diagram states that
the language is recognized recognized by
the algebra a so this needs to be a
finite quotient of T Sigma
and again if you look at the instances
this is exactly the classical
recognition in this example here of
languages by finite monoliths so the
recognizable languages are exactly the
classical regular languages if you look
at this other example you get exactly
the regular languages of finite and
infinite words so it seems to work let's
say by judging judging from these two
examples all right so this is how Mon
arts come into the picture what about
duality now if you look at the classical
allenburg theorem then somehow stone
duality plays a role in the background
one can see it essentially by looking at
Pinterest result from 97 so first of all
here we have stone duality so we have
the category of stone spaces which is
duly equivalent to boolean algebras
opposite for dual equivalent to boolean
algebras what's also playing a role for
us that this is the profile night
completion of finite sets and now
there's the stone space of profile night
words which is the inverse limit of all
finite quotient monoliths of Sigma star
and this turns out to be dual to the
regular languages and this is
essentially glimpse of this island berg
correspondence appearing i would say and
what's important for us is that this
correspondence or this duel
correspondence between the profile night
mono eat and regular languages this
works in this general setting for more
arts so generalizes from sigma star to
arbitrary more nuts ok let's look at
this so we have our manar tandy as
before and now we need some more we need
another local infinite variety so that's
another assumption that we have to make
such that actually with more than this
year what we need is that the finite
algebras NC a
equivalent to the finite algebra sandy
and then this follows so if you take the
pro completion of the finite algebra
Cindy this th this becomes dual
equivalent to see what we need and then
instances of this is of course Stone
duality as we've seen so you've got
million algebras here in stone spaces
here and finite sets here you could take
priestly duality or you could take
vector spaces C and D and then you get
stone vector spaces here in the middle
and there are some other instances the
role of this free profile night mono it
is now played by doing the same
construction that we saw before but now
with T algebra so you take the inverse
limit of all finite quotient algebras of
free other ground Sigma and let's call
it t head Sigma and this is going to be
the way profi night T algebra actually
this becomes a Mon art on the head which
we call the profile at one art and it's
a thing we have seen yesterday in that
you last talk maybe that's this code NZ
team on art logicians also few for those
category aficionados among you now this
output object here this is not a
parameter you put but it's somehow now
once you chose this duality here on the
finite level is somehow forced upon you
what you should take namely you should
take the dual of the free one generated
algebra and see this must be output
object otherwise this the rest is not
working but it's the right thing in the
examples and now what you can prove is
and this is a little theorem you have to
show is that the recognizable language
is are just yeah isomorphic one-to-one
correspondence with the morphisms in
this row completion d head from t hat
sigma to all so previously languages
were morphism from t sigma to all
factorizing threw something at algebra
and this somehow then
appears if you talk about from profile
ID and then going on using the duality
one sees that well since always 20 21
and you have to turn round things here
so this is the same as the sea morphisms
from one to the duel of T head sigma and
so that's the essentially the elements
of the duel of tea at Sigma so what this
says is that the recognizable languages
can be viewed as an object insignia and
this is now kind of a general version of
this regular languages are dual to the
free profile at one rate we see in our
setting and then this this t hat is
actually very important for the proofs
but it's not going to reappear in the
talk from now on alright so back to the
statement of Iron Works variety theorem
so there it is so now we wanna I want to
massage this and replace bits and pieces
and get to this statement of the general
I'm Burke's theorem so first of all
modern rates of course are going to be
replaced by T algebras well in the year
by 40 years later because that's easy uh
all the closure properties your quotient
sub algebras and finite products that
make sense for T algebras just what you
what you know on the left hand side it's
going to be a bit more difficult so
first of all saying a subset of the
regular language is closed under boolean
operations what's what's that supposed
to be so we've replaced stone duality so
boolean algebra sandstone spaces by
something more abstract so what we
should get is what corresponding to the
boolean algebra so that's this category
C here and well some subset closed under
something is just a sub object so these
Sigma is going to be a sub object of the
recognizable language is considered as
an object is in see as we can do it let
us show you before and then closed under
these two things now of these two things
the second one is is
le straightforward or it's
straightforward you again replace just
Manu it by T algebra and morphisms
between free monoliths by morphisms
between T algebra observing that pre
images you get by recomposing with such
a morphism so that's pretty
straightforward now the important bit is
what happens to the derivatives and
that's really the in some sense the crux
of the matter so let's look at the
classical I'm back theorem again for a
while so there we have these derivatives
on both sides and they correspond to
unary operations on Sigma star given by
words or single letters composed on both
sides of word and now the language
derivative of L is just given by taking
l as a predicate and composing it with
the unary operation ok something similar
is what we need and then the important
observation here is that from these
unary operations you can actually
recover the mono its structure of
quotients of Sigma star so if you have
any subjective map from Sigma star then
this carries a quotient going to eat if
you have a lifting property with respect
to all these unary operations namely
every one of these youn'uns lifts to the
quotient
this is what we need and this is what
we're going to use as as the definition
now so what we need is that our Mona is
not just any Mona whatsoever but we also
need a good unit representation on it so
that's a bunch of unary operations such
that any quotient in this category D
carries a quotient T algebra if and only
if all these unary operations lift along
e so that's it the same property now of
course it's true that if you have for
example if a Natori menard on sets there
always is such a union representation
which you can construct its canonical
but it's probably useless because it's
too big and unwieldy so this is why we
decided to make this another parameter
of the framework and is this this is
where I think for automata theorists the
challenge is to come up with such a
presentation that's good but for for
what we are after it's it's going to be
a parameter and with the help of such
union representation it's now easy to
say what is the derivative because if
you have the language and the unary
operation you just do pre composition
and that's your drive language so coming
back to this statement of the general
i'm back theorem it's not easy to say
closed under derivatives you just plug
in what I just said so we must have this
unit representation then for all you
nari operations if you have el in V
Sigma its derivative is also in vc okay
so there is the generalized I'm the
variety theorem and now how to prove
this well you do realize of course this
is oversimplifying because obviously I
mean if you look at these two things
they're not obviously doing so there is
some beautiful non-trivial work going on
in the background but that's in the
paper and I won't tell you about this
but at the core
there is a dual ization going on so
actually there's something in between
here which is profile at theories and
this is where the code NZT mon that
plays a role and so you first go from
the Sulu varieties to what we call
profile night theories and then you do
lie something and then you come back to
varieties of languages all right so
applications so as I said we have this
duality on the finite level the monarch
the unit representation they all
parameters and depending on applications
there might be other stuff and there
might be some properties that these
things have to satisfy that's all in the
paper I don't want to go into this
anyway then you get out of this theorem
more than a dozen varieties theorems
that are known in the literature maybe
all of them that I listed before so all
these are instances and you also get new
results out of this for example I
mentioned this local ironwork theorem of
Google go big wave in power and since
the proof is kind of modular in a sense
that we establish a local I'm Greg
theorem and then we kind of leave it up
to the to the real thing that full
general I'm Burke variety theorem so we
get local versions for all of these more
than a dozen theorems as well and most
of them are not known so they are no
alright that's essentially it so so the
take home message from this talk is that
Island Burke is essentially monarchs
plus dualities so what we've seen is a
categorical approach to algebraic
language series using monarchs and so we
rejoined previous work by we uncheck and
by ourselves in this work here we saw
that we get this general Amburg theorem
with many applications to be quite
honest what it does I mean it doesn't
take away all the work from from people
interested in automata theory it somehow
isolates the common algebraic parts of
these proofs of these ironwork type
correspondences so there's always
non-trivial work that lies in finding
the right monad so if you start with
some kind of finite machine behaviors
you still have to find the right
algebras and you still have to find for
once you have the MA not a good unary
presentation because this will
correspond to the derivatives that
you're looking at but we think that the
whole framework that we have kind of
helps because once you have that the
rest is kind of automatic and so maybe
it helps to focus on the things that
really matter there's further work
that's not future work that's actually
something that we've done there's also a
general writer man theorem which relates
to the varieties that we saw on the
right hand side to profile at equations
which are kind of a syntactic way to
specify these pseudo varieties rather
than characterizing them by closure
properties so that's fairly recent then
there's the question what about non
regular languages because recently and
some years ago there's work where
allenburg type correspondences were
proved for non regular languages and
they currently wouldn't be direct
instances of what we have but we're
really convinced that the kind of
methods we have would allow us to
get a theorem that would cover them as
well so this is why this ? is small in
oly and ray so in particular I think
hanging has already written this up then
may speculatively one could be
interested in a nominal version so I'm
web theorem for data languages but this
is so there are two question marks
because we think is quite hard so
there's no manual stone duality in the
work of gab I litre completely shot but
it's a very unclear how to get an iron
Berg type correspondence and then maybe
something like magnetic second-order
logic for Ramon art and I don't know
what that should be questions leave a
comment one other things fanatic second
or love Ramona so in my paper there is a
proof for that covers melodic
second-order logic and all known
examples it's so on a set yeah yeah
that's what non-example sleep and
another at this one is the question is
you have this
presentations so when I was trying to
put item Burke's theorem Mona I used a
notion of derivative in the sense of
there's 2i to to actually alternative
definition one of them is a derivative a
lap of a language is anything recognized
by its syntactic algebra how then you
don't need to specify the parameter it's
just there how does that I mean how does
that extend to but this is the you used
two polynomials that's the other way
polynomials are maybe don't extend so
clearly two categories be on set so I
didn't want to mention them but the
other one I think it does so does it
instantiate to the theorems that you
know okay so then I would have to look
more closely at this again but so in our
setting this was precisely the reason to
have these unity presentations so that
you have something that corresponds
exactly to the derivatives you see in
applications that's that's the case